i got a ton of emails from people saying
david there is a new straw poll out
for republicans in 2024 and trump
isn't winning you've got to talk about
it so i'm going to talk about it but
for better or worse i don't know if this
will bring pleasure or disdain or
sadness to people in the audience it's a
pretty meaningless poll
this is a poll from the western
conservative
summit and indeed republican florida
governor ron desantis
won over donald trump in this
straw poll that was conducted on
saturday
now let's look at the numbers this is a
poll
in which ron desantis came in first with
74
donald trump was second with 71
then you have ted cruz at 42 percent
mike pompeo
at 39 and tim scott at 35
now why is this a meaningless poll
result
it's meaningless because this is number
one it's a long time from now
first of all number two this is an
approval
poll so there are two things that make
it meaningless
for us for identifying trump's actual
chances
in 2024 number one it just asks you
do you approve of trump desantis whoever
not do you support them in 2024 as the
republican nominee
and number two you can vote uh yes
essentially i approve
for more than one person that's why it
doesn't add up to a hundred percent
desantis 74
trump 71. so this tells us
very very little about what's going to
go on in 2024
but i still think that there are some
interesting things to glean from this
why is it that desantis is doing well
desantis is doing well because he is a
more competent and i believe far more
dangerous version
of trump's authoritarian lunacy in a
sense
desantis is more trumpian than trump
to the degree that he can better
communicate his harebrained ideas
that he shares with donald trump himself
we've talked before about you know could
donald trump's presidency open the door
to an even dumber and even more
incompetent version of trump that
republicans would vote for the answer is
absolutely uh as i've said earlier and
before
if you overstate the intelligence of the
republican electorate you will be
disappointed
we thought in 2015 2016 okay there's a
lot of ignorant republicans who are
easily tricked
but they're not going to vote for trump
they're not this ignorant and then they
did
so could they vote for someone even
worse than trump
in terms of cartoonish incompetence yes
but the risk about desantis
is that he's more competent than donald
trump he's an authoritarian nut
with delusions based on supply-side
economic ideas and
religious conservatism and all this
stuff but he is more competent than
trump
he is more coherent in the presentation
of these bad ideas
and that has the potential to make him
far more dangerous than donald trump
actually is and that's a
really really scary thing so on the one
hand
it's an approval poll you can say i
approve of desantis
and i approve of trump um and
so that makes it of limited value to us
right now for 2024
it's also approval rather than who would
you vote for
it's also still the first half of 2021
so there are limited things we can glean
from this but if i am to glean
one thing here it's that donald trump's
worst uh instincts are present
in ron desantis and packaged more
competently
in terms of desantis's delivery and
quite frankly
desantis being from florida florida we
don't know what the map
is going to look like in 2024 a lot of
it will depend on how does 2022 go and
how much voter suppression is there and
many other things
but there is no doubt that if florida is
important
desantis as the republican nominee could
play
a very very big role there as well so
don't read too much into this
but an interesting straw poll
nonetheless